bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur public sénat au programme
des sénateurs ce matin l'examen en
seconde lecture du projet de loi sur
l'avenir de l'agriculture un texte qui a
déjà été adopté par les députés le 11
juillet alors l'objectif de ce projet de
loi est bien c'est de prendre le virage
de l'agro écologie
concrètement l'idée de produire plus
avec moins moins d'énergie moins de
chiny moins d'eau aussi et tout cela
pour renforcer la compétitivité de
l'agriculture et pour favoriser cette
conversion est bien le texte prévoit
notamment la création de génie de
groupement d'intérêt économique et
environnementale au sein de ce
groupement est bien les agriculteurs
pourraient se regrouper et bénéficier
des aides préférentiels alors selon le
ministre de l'agriculture stéphane le
foll il y aurait entre 10000 et 12000
agriculteurs parmi les 490 exploitations
agricoles qui devraient être concernés
par cette disposition
enfin parmi les mesures qui ont été très
débattue à l'assemblée nationale lors de
l'examen du texte il y a bien évidemment
en usage des pesticides à proximité de
certaines zones dites sensibles des
zones comme les écoles les hôpitaux ou
encore les maisons de retraite et bien
après de ces zones désormais il faudra
et cela sous peine de sanctions prendre
certaines mesures de protection comme
par exemple la mise en place de haies ou
encore la fixation d'horaires adaptés
autre mesure très discutée lors de
toujours de cet examen à l'assemblée
nationale eh bien l'abattage des noues
il sera désormais autorisée mais là
aussi sous certaines conditions et dans
certaines zones du territoire mais tout
de suite direction l'hémicycle
poursuivre l'examen de ce texte très
bonne matinée à tous sur notre chaîne
jeu monsieur le ministre vous avez la
parole
madame la présidente indépendamment du
fait que
moi évidemment c'est un très grand
honneur et un très grand plaisir d'être
au sénat ce matin et de faire avancer
cette loi très important de la loi
agricole vous comprendrez bien que ma
présence ici est justifiée parce que
nous le savons mon collègue stéphane le
foll a eu un petit moment de fatigue il
est aujourd'hui encore retenus pour
des examens complémentaires mais sur une
situation sur lesquels nous n'avons
absolument pas à nous inquiéter mais
néanmoins c'est son absence qui excuse
qui explique ma présence à ce vent est
évidemment vous pouvez en être certains
je m'appliquerai à répondre précisément
et rapidement
à l'ensemble des interventions de nos
collègues
merci monsieur le ministre et merci de
nous rassurera sur et sur la santé de
monsieur le ministre de l'agriculture
l'ordre du jour appelle la suite de la
discussion en deuxième lecture du projet
de loi d'avenir pour l'agriculture
l'alimentation et la forêt nous en
sommes parvenus à la discussion des
articles
articles 1er un amendement numéro 39
présentée par monsieur le cam pour le
persil wallemme la présidente monsieur
mini chers collègues cet amendement de
mme un collègue evelyne didier de la
commission et développement durable
cergy à l'article 1er donc du projet de
loi qui définit les buts de la politique
en faveur de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation ils appellent donc des
textes d'application des lois ou des
règlements le projet de loi précise que
la politique en faveur de l'agriculture
et de l'alimentation dans ses dimensions
internationales européennes nationales
et territoriales a pour finalité
notamment en ce 11 nouveaux de protéger
et valoriser les terres agricoles c'est
à jouer très important parce
qu'aujourd'hui certaines pratiques
existent qui met à mal de tels objectifs
je veux parler ici de l'enfouissement et
du dépôt de déchets est particulièrement
des déchets dits inertes souhait sur les
terres agricoles par notre amendement
nous vous demandons de mettre au rang
des objectifs celui de l'interdiction de
telles pratiques qui contreviennent à la
préservation des terres agricoles d'une
part il nous semble que la législation
actuelle n'interdit pas le stockage de
déchets inertes sur des terres agricoles
ainsi en vertu de l'article l541 30 1 du
code de l'environnement aucune
autorisation administrative n'est
nécessaire pour les installations où les
déchets inertes sont entreposés pour une
durée inférieure à trois ans ce qui pose
déjà un problème de contrôle le 3
soustrait également ses déchets à
autorisation administrative pour
l'utilisation de déchets inertes pour la
réalisation de travaux d'aménagement de
réhabilitation ou à des fans
construction cela a permis à des
entreprises de déverser les déchets
inertes sur les chemins forestiers ou
sur des terres agricoles de plus le code
de l'urbanisme dispense de délivrance de
permis d'aménager les affouillements et
exaucement du sol dont la hauteur ne
dépassent pas deux mètres et qui porte
sur une superficie inférieure à 2
hectares ainsi aucune autorisation n'est
nécessaire et donc aucun contrôle
effectué quand ces déchets qui sont
enfouis sous les terres agricoles est
recouvert ensuite sans avoir été bâchée
c'est ce qui s'est passé récemment en
seine-et-marne il faut savoir que d'une
part les terres agricoles peuvent être
couvertes de mauvaise taire et laisser
ensuite à l'abandon on ne peut pas dire
que leur reconversion en décharge soit
une valorisation
d'autre part il arrive qu'elles soient à
nouveau cultiver là se pose le problème
de la capillarité ascendantes et
descendantes quelque peu gêné par les
couches de déchets mais également la
présence de déchets dangereux d'arsenic
de plomb de métaux lourds qui infiltrent
les eaux et les ter les membres des
commissions foncière la chambre
d'agriculture et la fdsea 77 se sont
penchés sur ces questions ils ont estimé
que les remblais de déchets inertes pose
question du fait des difficultés à
pouvoir contrôler la nature des dépôts
olivier georges secrétaire général
adjoint déclaré l'histoire nous rappelle
chaque jour que certaines terres sont
aujourd'hui polluée par des
entrepreneurs peu scrupuleux
ainsi par cet amendement mes chers
collègues au delà de la question de la
pollution de l'eau qui est une question
essentielle comme en témoignent les
contaminations de trop nombreux captage
d'eau se pose également la question de
la préservation du potentiel agronomique
des terres agricoles c'est pourquoi nous
aimerions que la législation sur les
déchets dits inertes soit renforcé et
par notre amendement directement en lien
avec la loi d'avenir agricole nous vous
demandons d'inscrire parmi les objectifs
celui de l'interdiction de
l'enfouissement des déchets sous les
terres agricoles je vous remercie si
monsieur le sénateur pour la commission
la vie de monsieur le rapporteur
présidente monsieur
mini chargé des relations avec le
parlement bienvenue pour cette loi
d'avenir sur l'agriculture et les
nouvelles que vous nous avez donné de
stéphane le foll nous rassurer nous
serons heureux de le retrouver très
rapidement au banc du gouvernement sa
présence nous manque déjà mais hier soir
madame delga et vous même monsieur le
ministre ce matin vous êtes des
remplaçants de luxe
c'est une c'est un bon amendement que
vous posez monsieur le cam je peux
comprendre son intérêt mais je ne
partage pas sa finalité je vais mettre
un avis défavorable vous le savez
pourquoi tout simplement parce qu'il
faut bien des endroits pour mettre les
déchets par exemple les déchets de
chantier ou autre donc si on supprime
les terres là où doit-on les maîtres
après dans la mer ailleurs on a un
problème des déchets il fera sûrement
avoir une réflexion globale mais là je
ne peux pas vous suivre sur cet
étalement de match donne un avis
défavorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre même un vis mal à la présidente
donc je vais mettre cet amendement au
voir
qui est pur avec avec avis défavorable
du gouvernement et de la commission
pardon qui et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient cet amendement n'est pas
adopté
je vais mettre aux voix l'article 1er
pas d'explications de vote qui et pour
qui et contre
l'article 1er est adopté
nous en arrivons à l'article 2 avec un
amendement numéro 138 présentée par
monsieur mézard
oui mais c'est monsieur colin excuses et
noir c'est pas grave c'est pas grave
bon
la présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues
man group a déposé cet amendement vous
devez donc le reconnaître en première
lecture nous souhaitions le soumettre
une nouvelle fois votre attention car
vous l'aurez compris nous y tenons
beaucoup
il s'agit si le rendre obligatoire
la présence des représentants des
interprofessions au sein des conseils
spécialisés de france agrimer dans le
dispositif actuel des interprofessions
sont simplement consulté faut-il le
rappeler à titre d'expert
l'article 2 renforce le rôle de
l'établissement public une instance qui
est déjà si je puis dire le bras armé de
la politique d'orientation des filières
agricoles vous le savez en effet
franceagrimer exerce des missions
fondamentales que sont au niveau
opérationnel pour l'exécution des
politiques de soutien aux filières
agricoles en matière d'information
économique par la collecte des données
sur les productions ou encore par
l'animation des filières à travers des
conseils spécialisés il serait par
conséquent nous semble-t-il logique
d'intégrer des représentants des
interprofessions au sein des conseils
spécialisés afin que le débat sur la
stratégie des filières soient menées
avec tous les acteurs concernés c'est le
sens de cet amendement que je vous
engage bien sûr à soutenir ardemment
merci monsieur le sénateur colin et avec
mes excuses monsieur le rapporteur pour
la commission merci madame la présidente
monsieur colin nous avons déjà beaucoup
parlé de votre amendement moi j'ai émis
un avis défavorable parce que les
interprofessions sont déjà représentées
au sein des conseils spécialisés dans
l'es11 et on pense que nous pensons que
ça pourrait faire redondance que c'est
pas utile donc je comprends l'intérêt de
flécher de marquer les interprofessions
je le prends comme un amendement d'appel
fort mais je vous demande soit de le
retirer soit vous serez contraint
d'émettre un avis défavorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur à vis du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre mais
ma vie même argumentation
impressionnante je vais donc mettre aux
voix cet amendement numéro 6 il est
retiré très bien merci je mets sauvoy
l'article 2 qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient cet article est donc
adopté
article 3 un amendement numéro 101
présentée par monsieur l'abbé pour le
groupe écologiste oui madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre chers
collègues
cet amendement de concert de la
méthanisation la méthanisation agricole
doit rester une activité complémentaire
à l'activité d'agriculteur et non pas
devenir le moteur de projets industriels
non pourvoyeur d'emplois agricoles est
source de dommages sanitaires et
environnementaux c'est pourquoi cet
amendement propose de fixer une limite à
la puissance des réacteurs permettant de
prétendre à la classification en
activité agricole cette puissance
maximale est fixée par décret
au-delà de la question de puissance les
méga méthaniseur s'inscrivent dans une
logique d'exploitation industrielle ont
des effets induits néfastes pour
l'environnement la santé et le bien-être
animal dans des élevages de plus en plus
concentrationnaire pollution des nappes
phréatiques par les boues d'épandage
recours intensif aux antibiotiques
ensuite transmis au lait à la viande
dans le cas des vaches en définitive il
s'agit d'établir que l'activité agricole
doit rester une activité liée à la
maîtrise et à l'exploitation d'un cycle
biologique de caractère végétales et
animales et non une activité
industrielle et c'est une part de
réponses aux méga projets comme celui
des millevaches parce qu'on n'a pas la
réponse par là et par la possibilité de
préemption safer et donc c'est une part
de réponse que de limiter la capacité
des méthaniseurs je crois qu'on nous
regarde on nous écoute à ce sujet là et
c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle je
le défend avec force je vous remercie
monsieur le sénateur pour la commission
monsieur le rapporteur votre avis oui
merci mon avis est défavorable parce que
nous ne partageons
nous avons une divergence de fond avec
monsieur avec monsieur l'abbé il le sait
personne ne veut des outrances personne
ne veut partir tous azimuts nafa on peut
aussi considérer que des professionnels
font des usines de méthanisation
respectant l'environnement il n'y a pas
de raison toujours de montrer du doigt
et de dire ça va être une catastrophe
dans le cadre d g 2e évidemment nous
avons la volonté cet outil qui est
exceptionnel qui va relancer
quelque part le collectif dans
l'agriculture il pourra y avoir des
usines de méthanisation fait à
l'intérieur mais ne faisons pas ça de
façon exclusive après toujours prendre
alors tantôt on prend en référence à
l'allemagne tantôt en critique
l'allemagne c'est pas le sujet ne nous
comparons pas d'autres comparent on ou
tout simplement à ce que nous faisons
nous voulons une agriculture
respectueuse de l'environnement nous
voulons des activités économiques qui
aillent dans le bon sens la
méthanisation et c'est quelque chose de
très important pour notre pays
travaillons surtout monsieur le ministre
monsieur des fois on est d'accord à
faire en sorte qu'il ne faille pas un an
ou deux ou trois ans avec tous les
recours fait par des uns et des autres
pour mettre en place un méthaniseur mais
qu'on puisse le faire de façon plus
rapide comme cela est le cas en
allemagne d'ailleurs il ne s'agit pas de
vouloir faire toujours plus gros ne
comparons pas lusine débile vaches ou
des 500 vaches à cet amendement je suis
au regret monsieur l'abbé de vous dire
que j'émets un avis défavorable moi je
crois en l'homme je crois en la
conscience collective et je crois en
l'évolution de la mentalité de nos
concitoyens des agriculteurs comme du
monde économique pour aller dans ce sens
et je veux réaffirmer ici en mon nom
personnel mais je pense que nous serons
tous d'accord que la diversification des
sources d'énergie et que la
méthanisation est quelque chose de très
important pour l'avenir de notre pays et
des déchets agricoles notamment merci
monsieur le rapporteur à vis du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre la
présidente évidemment nous sommes tous
ici mobilisés sur les problématiques de
transition énergétique et dans cette
problématique de transition énergétique
nous savons qu'une des données c'est
aussi d'aller vite dans le cadre de
cette transition énergétique aussi
mettre des normes nouvelles nous semble
pas du tout l'esprit dans lequel nous
devons travailler il peut y avoir des
projets tout à fait intéressant d'abord
pour l'environnement globalement sinon
avance avec une puissance supérieure
aussi dans le cadre de ce projet agro
écologique que nous présentons pour la
france le fameux plan emma qui
privilégie des projets collectifs de
méthanisation agricole ou plusieurs
agriculteurs se regroupent autour d'un
projet conçu dans une logique d'ancrage
territorial et dans le respect de la
diversité des territoires c'est cette
vision là que nous voulons mettre en
avant donc ils ne sont pas appropriés de
brider la reconnaissance du caractère
agricole des projets par l'ajout d'un
plafonnement de la puissance de
l'installation
voilà monsieur le sénateur ce qui est
nous semble correspondre à un souci à la
fois une logique agricole et d'une
logique environnementale vu dans sa
globalité merci monsieur mini jeu mais
se voit cet amendement numéro 101 qui a
reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission un avis défavorable du
gouvernement monsieur l'abbé pour une
explication de vote ou simplement pour
répondre à notre chère rapporteur didier
guillaume moi aussi je crois en l'homme
mais je me méfie par rapport à la par
rapport à l'aspect appât du gain pour
pour certains regroupement d'hommes je
vous remercie merci monsieur de noeuds
pour une explication de vote pour le
groupe ump
excusez moi et je peu près contre cet
amendement mais je voudrais à cette
occasion redire une nouvelle fois qu'il
faut se méfier des comparaisons entre la
france et l'allemagne sur ce système de
méthanisation
les différences sont telles qu'il faut
faire attention sur le plan technique
monsieur l'abbé moi je participe aux
travaux du
dauphine franco-allemand de des énergies
renouvelables 14 février dernier on a
fait points à l'ambassade d'allemagne
une journée entière sur les programmes
de méthanisation il y as en allemagne
7240 méthaniseur au travail en france
c'est moins de quelques dizaines ce jour
là on a 10 10 est bon mais quand tu as
graitec des méthaniseurs est la
composition des choses qu'on mais il y a
des problèmes techniques pour gérer un
méthaniseur qui font qu en allemagne
contrairement en france on a autorisé
une culture dédié bon donc on trouve un
équilibre en important
de l'énergie à partir il vit en
allemagne on estime l'ambassadeur nous
dit il faudrait voir ces chiffres on
estime qu'il ya 7000 hectares de maïs
qui servent à faire des la méthanisation
parlera point il est difficile de gérer
un méthaniseur avec une exploitation
agricole qui n'a que des déjections
animales notamment des déjections
animales de bovins donc en france on a
corrigé on a accepté des cultures
dédiées en cultures dérobées il faut
mettre tout ça dans l'ensemble pour voir
quelle est la bonne taille en plus il y
a des projets nécessaires avec des
petites villes dont il décrit ménagers
sont une richesse qu'on enfouit donc il
faut être très prudent pour parler de
taille si on compare pas des techniques
et les choses coquet l'on veut aboutir
donc moi je voterai contre cet
amendement parce qu'il faut laisser les
choses évoluer et elles vont se créa
c'est au fur et à mesure il nous faudra
plusieurs années pour que nous jouons
rejoignons le bon niveau de
méthanisation l'objectif c'est de
méthaniser tous les déchets ménagers
plutôt que lui et met à la poubelle
merci monsieur le sénateur monsieur le
cam oui nous soutiendront également cet
amendement tout en voulant attirer
l'attention du gouvernement sur quelques
travers de la métallisation à tout prix
notamment pour l'élevage laitier c'est
une véritable catastrophe pour l'élevage
laitier si on pousse à la méthanisation
ça veut dire qu'on enferme les vaches
pendant trois ans on les maintient en
fermer c'est plus le bien-être animal
c'est véritablement catastrophique
autant ça peut bien correspondre à
l'élevage porcin où l élevage de
volailles je crois qu'il faut qu'on soit
très prudent là dessus par ailleurs cet
amendement il a il a l'intérêt de
laisser le pouvoir au gouvernement de
fixer par décret la puissance maximale
je pense que les expériences communes de
plusieurs agriculteurs en matière de
métallisation sont également à
encourager pour autant avec en tenant
compte de ce que j'ai dit auparavant je
pense à géotexia dans le mené chez nous
c'est une belle expérience pour
l'instant et je crois que là il faut il
faut bien faire la part des choses de
très nombreux agriculteurs nous disent
ce n'est pas notre métier nous notre
métier c'est produire du lait par
exemple c'est pas de produire
d'électricité
donc je crois qu'il faut il faut qu'on
tienne les deux bouts si je puis dire de
cette affaire et je soutiendrai donc cet
amendement numéro 101 merci monsieur le
sénateur monsieur le noir vous avez la
peau très rapidement madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre je suis
tout à fait hostile à cet amendement
doit absolument incroyable il vient d'un
représentant du groupe écologiste on
sait que la biomasse un bel avenir en
france et que à l'intérieur à biomasse
et la méthanisation or d'un point de vue
technique confire collègues ya un seuil
critique en dessous duquel
l'investissement n'est pas rentable et
deuxièmement notre marque notre collègue
marcel deneux avez raison de souligner
c'est la question de l'apport des
produits qui entrent dans deux
digesteurs il faut qu'il y ait une
opération collective comme l'a très bien
rappelé d'ailleurs le ministre pour
réussir la méthanisation alors
aujourd'hui vous êtes en train d'en
fermer la méthanisation dans un étau qui
fera qu' elle ne sera pas rentable
qu'elle ne sera pas efficiente si
monsieur le sénateur je ne vois plus de
demandes d'explications de vagues je
mets donc aux voix cet amendement numéro
100 qui a reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission un avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient cet
amendement n'est pas adopté un
amendement numéro 27 rectifié monsieur
la serl défend
madame la présidente michèle collègues
nous nous
nous représentons cet amendement que
nous avions déjà déposé en première
lecture et qui avait été adopté par le
sénat malheureusement les députés ont
supprimé en deuxième lecture j'espère
que le sénat donc aujourd'hui revisitera
et confirmera son attitude lors du
premier passage cet amendement concerne
les groupements d'intérêts économiques
et environnementaux nous considérons que
léger léger i2e sont une excellente
initiative qui vont dans le sens de
l'innovation
et notre amendement vise justement à
donner pourrais je dire de la
prolificité au travail qui sera engagée
ces groupements ont vocation à appuyer
la mise en réseau des exploitations les
plus innovantes c'est quelque chose qui
peut devenir extrêmement important et
dans le but de faire bénéficier de ses
innovations le plus grand nombre
d'agriculteurs afin d'engager une
évolution massive des importations vers
la performance économique écologique et
social il est donc nous semble utile
nécessaire de rattacher des travaux d
j2ee et de capitaliser et de diffuser
les enseignements auprès d'organismes de
développement dont c'est la mission est
pour une réelle efficacité du dispositif
nous considérons que les ide doivent
être mis en réseau afin qu'une
innovation imaginez sur un territoire
puissent bénéficier à d'autres et
susciter de nouvelles idées les g2 au
son d'une très belle initiative rendons
les productifs et rendant les donc
généralisable au plus grand nombre par
l'intermédiaire notamment de notre
proposition d'amendement merci monsieur
le sénateur pour la commission monsieur
le rapporteur merci madame la présidente
monsieur lasserre
si j'osais je vous demanderais bien de
retirer votre amendement
pourquoi parce que parfois on fait des
grands écarts mais nous l'avons le sénat
a voté en première lecture l'amendement
de monsieur césar et l'amendement de
monsieur nasser sur ce sujet mais nous
n'étions pas très au point de lyon il
faut clarifier verrouillé de trois
choses et avancer entre temps nous avons
travaillé et l'assemblée nationale a
transformé
l'amendement était d'un texte en ne
donnant pas le monopole parce que les
monopoles c'est jamais bon dans aucun
sens mais redonnant le pilotage aux
chambres d'agriculture
donc à partir de là il me semble avis du
rapporteur que à partir du moment où les
chambres d'agriculture ont le pilotage
de l'animation nous avons les garanties
et je vous demanderai de retirer votre
amendement pour ne pas donner le
monopole il me semble que dans là qu'on
appelle dans l'écriture de l'assemblée
nationale il n'est pas totalement
satisfait si on est très objectif mais
il est globalement satisfait
merci monsieur le record est favorable à
vis du gouvernement peut-être qu'après
je vous redonne la parole monsieur la
série glee est favorable à la pression
merci donc pour une explication de vote
ou une réponse à la question qui vous a
été posée monsieur la sers
toi je le prendrais de monsieur le
rapporteur tout aux situations de
monopole y compris pour la diffusion
quelque chose de fâcheux de
moi je ne suis pas absolument garanti
par leur décision qui a été prise de
conférer ceci aux chambres d'agriculture
je serais même prêt à modifier un peu le
texte pour ouvrir le champ de la
diffusion des résultats des travaux des
génies 2e si la réponse est favorable là
dessus et je suis prêt à retirer
l'amendement bien entendu
monsieur à porter
il va trouver sur leurs portes
le 15 oui c'est les alinéas 15-16-17 la
page 13 du texte delà de la commission
je vous permet de lire ces trois années
à madame la maison prix présidente
le sait prévoir les modalités de
regroupement de diffusion de
réutilisation des résultats obtenus sur
les plans économiques environnementales
et sociales donc la linea 15 la
coordination des actions menées en vue
de la capitalisation et de la diffusion
des résultats des groupements des dg 2e
est assurée en lien avec les organismes
de développement agricole intéressé
alinéa 16 petits tas au niveau régional
par la chambre régionale d'agriculture
sous le contrôle du représentant de
l'état dans la région et du président du
conseil régional et petit b alinéa 17 au
niveau national par l'apc à l'assemblée
permanente des chambres d'agriculture
sous le contrôle du ministre chargé de
l'agriculture or il me semble que cette
rédaction va donc soit retrait ou avis
défavorable
donc cet amendement est retiré
nous passons à l'amendement numéro 99
monsieur l'abbé pour le groupe
écologiste
oui madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre chers collègues le sénat
restreint la pratique de l'échangé des
semences entre agh entre agriculteurs
roger u2 eux seuls cette disposition
risque de détourner les jeunes 2e de
leur finalité de détourner les
subventions j2ee de leur objectif final
de plus cet alinéa restreindrait la
portée de l'article l 325 1 du code
rural qui définit l'entr'aide entre
exploitants en ce qui concerne les
changes de semences de fermes et qui
n'est pas limitée à un périmètre ainsi
cet amendement propose de revenir sur la
restriction imposée par le sénat en
première lecture
merci monsieur le sénateur pour la
commission avis du rapporteur monsieur
le président ghislain avis défavorable
monsieur la belle sait bien nous l'avons
vu en commission en première lecture
puis en en séance en première lecture
puis en commission en deuxième lecture
plus nous voyons en séance en deuxième
lecture ça fait partie du débat la
navette gelé d'hier les deux précédentes
loi de 2006 et 2009 n'avait eu qu'une
lecture on n'aurait pas eu la chance si
on n'a vu qu'une lecture de reparler de
ce sujet pourquoi j'y suis défavorable
parce que de façon très encadrée à
l'intérieur des j2ee les changes de
semences est possible mais pas à
l'extérieur nous créons un marché
parallèle donc je ne suis pas d'accord
quand vous dites le sénat restera à vous
avez dit le sénat restreint
le sénat restera la peau de nom le sénat
ne resterait rien le sénat revient à une
lecture assez clair pas des changes de
semences pas de marché parallèle en
dehors des génies 2e donc c'est un avis
défavorable monsieur l'abbé merci
merci monsieur le rapporteur pour le
gouvernement monsieur le ministre un oui
merci maintenant présente effectivement
nous sommes tout à fait défavorable à
cet amendement et je voudrais préciser
qu'au contraire le texte ou aujourd'hui
un petit peu plus de possibilités
puisque
c'est uniquement une présomption
d'entr'aide termes juridiques précis
validé par le conseil d'état qui laisse
une part de responsabilité aux
agriculteurs alors que considéré relevé
de l'entraînent serait de ce point de
vue n'est acceptable mais vous le notez
nous élargissons les les possibilités et
donc je pense que vous devriez en
prendre acte et peut-être à votre tour
retirer c'est un moment
merci monsieur le ministre
je mets aux voix cet amendement numéro
99 monsieur l'abbé donc à la demande de
monsieur le ministre de retrait sur cet
amendement je vais le retirer bien que
j'ai encore quelques doutes mais je leur
tire et monsieur le sénateur amendement
numéro 127 toujours monsieur l'abbé pour
le groupe écologiste
s'il 127 ou 222 parce que
excusez moi oui
activement de précisions sur la
définition de la méthanisation agricole
collective qui sera encouragée dans le
cadre des j2ee voilà donc c'est
simplement une précision à vis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
madame la présidente comme ça sera pas
toute la journée comme cela je voulais
dire avec un grand sourire et beaucoup
d'entrain du jeu donné un avis favorable
à cet amendement de monsieur l'abbé
merci monsieur le rapporteur à vis du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
favorable
donc je vais mettre aux voix cet
amendement qui a reçu deux avis
favorables
l'inde la commission l'autre du
gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient cet amendement est adopté
on continue avec monsieur l'abbé pour
l'amendement numéro 122
oui madame la présidente monsieur bien
sûr collègues on en vient à la question
de la méthanisation
cet amendement vise à encourager la
reconversion des élevages sur quel les
élevages de porcs sur caillebotis en
élevage sur litière végétale dont le
potentiel méthanogène et la rentabilité
finale un meilleur en association avec
la méthanisation pour produire du
méthane il faut du carbone le lisier
comprend 95% d'eau tout le monde le sait
et le reste est très peu méthanogènes le
fumier obtenu en élevage sur paille pour
possède un pouvoir méthanogène bien
supérieur et c'est aussi un amendement
pour enrichir le terreau le le terreau
et et refaire l'humus dont on a besoin
alors en priorité refaire le terreau un
fumier et en supplément servir
heureusement et positivement à la
méthanisation je crois que là c'est une
vraie bonne réponse et sans parler du
bien-être animal parce que les élevages
de porcs sur caillebotis dans une
société humaine c'est pas terrible merci
monsieur le sénateur amis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
madame la présidente monsieur le
sénateur c'est parce que c'est une vraie
bonne nouvelle un vraiment à bandes
blanches je vais donner un avis
défavorable parce que je pense que vous
êtes non mais sérieusement je pense
qu'ils vous devriez le retirer monsieur
l'abbé chez tenter de vous expliquer
pourquoi ils ministre peut-être tout à
l'heure le fera avec beaucoup plus de
succès que moi je partage ce que vous
dite pourquoi pas pourquoi pas mais ce
n'est pas dans la loi enfin on va pas
faire des lois bavarde de 3000 pages on
va dire ben on va mettre les ports sur
caillebotis et puis pourquoi pas
d'autres pourquoi pas d'autres pourquoi
pas d'autres ce n'est pas de la loi ça
c'est une pratique agraire qui peut se
faire une pratique d'élevage donc moi je
suis pas défavorable à votre à votre
proposition qui peut être intéressante
mais je ne crois pas qu'on puisse mettre
ça dans la loi alors ça veut dire ce
serait exclusif de tout le reste non
pour l'instant nous ne sommes pas à même
nous ne sommes pas capables de mettre
cela excuse et de tout le reste donc
c'est un bel amendement d'appel je pense
que c'est bien ce que vous avez dit que
ça comptera beaucoup d'éleveurs de votre
sensibilité et d'autres sensibilités
mais vraiment monsieur l'abbé je vous
demande dans l'intérêt global de retirer
cet amendement ça serait ennuyeux qu'on
soit obligé de voter contre q le sénat
vote contre quelque chose qui peut être
intéressant qui peut avoir de l'avenir
mais qui ne peut pas rentrer dans la loi
donc je fais pas comme ça pour endormir
mais c'est ça pourquoi pas mais pas dans
la loi donc retiré le vous l'avez
présentez vous l'avez argumenter vos
frais une explication de vote et je
pense que ce sera bien merci monsieur le
rapporteur habits du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre un président tu le
gouvernement est intéressé par l'idée
mais par contre ils soulignent
auprès du législateur l'idée que nous ne
pouvons pas tout écrire dans la loi que
donc ces précisions par ailleurs
intéressante n'ont pas à être inscrits
dans le cadre législatif est donc
peut-être que vous serez entendu et que
le mieux ce serait de retirer cet
amendement
monsieur merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur le sénateur l'abbé corps et
pendez vous à cette question oui
madame la présidente monsieur ministre
cher collègue monsieur le rapporteur
j'ai eu un moment de doute vous avez pu
constater ma bonne volonté pour ce qui
est des retraites hélas là et puis
j'entends dire loi bavarde ce n'est pas
du tout du bavardage et est vraiment là
je ne peux pas le retirer cet amendement
je le maintiens merci donc je vais
mettre aux voix cet amendement qui a
reçu deux avis défavorables de la
commission et du gouvernement qui et
pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient cet
amendement n'est pas adopté nous en
avons nous en venons à deux amendements
identiques faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune d'abord l'amendement
numéro 86 madame nique où vous avez la
parole oui merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement propose de réintroduire
une disposition autorisant les échanges
de céréales entre membres de j2ee sans
être tenu un passage physique par un
collecteur agréé je vous rappelle que
cette disposition était présente dans le
projet de loi initial et a été supprimée
en première lecture à l'assemblée
nationale afin de répondre aux
inquiétudes soulevées par lors de son
examen nous l'avions réintroduite au
sénat en précisant que ces échanges
resteraient soumis aux déclarations
statistiques et au versement des taxes
prélevées en règle générale lors du
passage en organismes stockeurs nous
apportions ainsi une réponse deux
grandes inquiétudes soulevées par les
députés en première lecture or cette
disposition a de nouveau été supprimée
en séance publique à l'assemblée
nationale notamment au motif que cela
ouvrait la voie à une désorganisation du
marché des céréales nous ne partageons
pas cette analyse
nous rappelons ici que cet amendement ne
permet pas une commercialisation sans
passage par l'organisme stocker en
dehors d'un j2ee c'est pourquoi nous
vous proposons de réintroduire cette
disposition qui va dans le sens d'une
simplification du fonctionnement des
génies 2e afin de favoriser l'action
collective et la complémentarité entre
exploitations qui madame la sénatrice
monsieur lecarme pour l'amendement
numéro 88 oui madame la présidente
monsieur michaud collègues cet
amendement vient de très bien défendue
par madame nique où il nous savons
sommes très attachés également à ces
échanges de semences depuis très
longtemps c'est pourquoi nous sommes
autorisés à reprendre le même pour lui
donner davantage de poids davantage de
résonance au sein de notre assemblée et
se faire en sorte aussi que au moment de
la cmp ils soient maintenues merci
monsieur le sénateur avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
mussidan de c'est un avis favorable sur
ces deux amendements que nous avions
présenté en première lecture que le
sénat avait voté que l'assemblée a
retiré on verra ce qui se passera en cmp
moi je suis d'avis de leur mettre des
garde-fous on peut pas faire n'importe
quoi donc nous avions bien verrouiller
sa en première en première lecture c'est
un interdit j2se c'est la différence de
ce qui vaut keita leur monsieur monsieur
l'abbé l'acier on parle bien des changes
à l'intérieur d'un j2ee toute façon il
faudra quand même passer par les
organismes collecteurs madame mikula
très bien présentés et également le
groupe crc donc je pense qu'il n'y a pas
de risque ya des garde-fous et je
propose de mettre un avis favorable
important rapide du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
vraiment le gouvernement y est favorable
merci merci je vais donc mettre aux voix
ces deux amendements
oui monsieur bailly vous avez la parole
vous êtes long seulement pour dire que
je voterai cet amendement parce qu'il me
semble simple simple vous savez que
d'alléger de deux heures on sait pas
trop encore exactement quelle voie de
l'être ces résultats et vous savez que
notre groupe nous avons encore quelques
interrogations là il ya quelque chose de
concrète positif est simple donc c'est
pourquoi personnellement je voterai cet
amendement plus merci monsieur le
sénateur je mets donc au voir ces deux
amendements qui ont reçu tous les deux
un avis favorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient ces deux amendements sont
adoptés nous en venons à l'amendement
numéro 125 présentée par monsieur l'abbé
pour le groupe écologiste pardon madame
la présidente monsieur le ministre chers
collègues cet amendement pourrait
paraître anecdotique il ne l'est pas du
tout et là encore m'appelant l'abbé je
pourrais avoir l'air de prêcher dans le
désert mais je sais que ce n'est pas
dans le désert parce que je sais que je
suis si ce n'est écouté au moins tendue
alors cet amendement vise à reconnaître
une pratique aujourd'hui largement
popularisé et de plus en plus largement
popularisé l'aide bénévole qui peut
prendre forme connue sous le nom connu
de wwoofing et qui se trouve
actuellement dans une situation
juridique très inconfortable si de
nombreux agriculteurs accueille ce qu'on
appelle les woofers ils manifestent de
plus en plus leurs craintes de voir cet
accueil et à juste titre requalifier en
travail déguisé par la msa cet
amendement permet donc de clarifier le
statut de l'aide bénévole et
d'encourager ce type des changes
profitable à la fois pour les
agriculteurs qui peuvent bénéficier de
coups de main transmettre leur passion
mais aussi refaire le lien entre la
population citadine ou périurbaines et
avec le métier d'agriculteur donc c'est
une nouvelle culture le c'est en cours
et ça va se continuer simplement le fait
de pouvoir
maître sur la donner la possibilité d'un
contrat d'être bénévole que les
conditions sont fixées par décret et ça
permet de clarifier les choses a quelque
chose qui existe je vous donne un tout
petit exemple sur ma commune de saint
nolff quand j'étais encore mr on a
présenté toute une ferme de 23 hectares
en utilisant les outils de la pub de la
puissance publique pour y installer une
marie cher et au début c'est au moins
une vingtaine de personnes qui sont
venues spontanément l'aider seulement ce
sens sans aucune sans aucun cadre
juridique et c'est le cas un contrat de
deux dates bénévoles et c'est plié et
pour autant pour l'agriculteur que pour
les que pour les personnes on se met au
clair m merci monsieur le sénateur à vis
à vis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
la présidente monsieur monsieur le
sénateur la bévue en première lecture vu
en deuxième
lecture vous l'avez quasiment 10 vous
même dans votre argumentation
ça pourrait s'apparenter à du travail
dissimulé l'entr'aide ce n'est pas le
wwoofing et nous voulons rester sur la
première partie qui dit entraide dit
contrepartie des retours et là ce n'est
pas le cas la terre aux paysans c'est un
slogan vous avions entendu nous nous
sommes pour la terre aux paysans et que
les agriculteurs fassent ce qu'ils ont
en face ce qu'ils ont à faire moi je
suis défavorable à cette a7 à cet
amendement franchement si on pousse le
bouchon un peu loin la direction du
travail pourrait venir ça peut
s'apparenter à du travail dissimulé je
ne suis pas favorable ne sommes pas dans
le wwoofing nous sommes dans l'antre
aide restons là où nous en sommes à vue
d'efforts merci monsieur le sénateur mr
important à vis du gouvernement monsieur
le ministre
oui mais là la présidente dit je pense
que cette assemblée comme l'autre a voté
récemment un
texte de loi encadrant les stages
et ayant avec beaucoup de prudence sur
les rapports au travail de gens qui
viennent soit disant de façon bénévole
donc je ne comprends pas comment on peut
ouvrir dans le droit du travail à
travers cette idée qui est qui a toutes
les apparences de la générosité mais
elle est une ouverture par rapport au
travail qui est tout à fait
problématique donc nous sommes
défavorables
si monsieur le ministre
je mets aux voix cet amendement qui a
reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission un avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient cet
amendement n'est pas adoptée jamais aux
voix l'article 3 du projet de loi qui et
pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient l'article 3 est adopté
nous en venons à l'article 4 avec cinq
amendements discussion commune je
commence par l'amendement numéro 10 est
rectifié monsieur lasserre vous avez la
parole
comme la présidente mes chers collègues
nous demandons la suppression des
alinéas 1 à 6 nous considérons on a eu
beaucoup de discussions de débats nous
considérons que les obligations déjà
existantes par exploitation sur les
cahiers d'épandage obligations imposées
par la réglementation et vérifiez
régulièrement par les contrôles suffit
je le crois à maîtriser le problème qui
nous et qui nous est posée l'article 4
concerne l'obligation de déclaration des
flux d'azoté il oblige les déclarations
sur les stockages les transports et nous
considérons que véritablement là on va
très très loin dans la complexité ça
peut presque relevé de l'inquisition et
les mesures déjà prises je le répète sur
les plans d'épandage devrait amplement
suffire pour apaiser les craintes ou les
objectifs de ceux qui considèrent qu'il
faut maîtriser ces situations
merci mais c'est le sénateur
l'amendement numéro 52 qui le défend
monsieur bailly
c'est le même bruit c'est le même
amendement et je crois qu'on a déjà eu
un débat en première lecture ces sujets
là et vous savez que c'est un sujet
aussi où notre groupe nous y sommes très
défavorable donc en deuxième lecture il
était aussi à reposer ce problème
aujourd'hui tout genton d'hier notre
rapporteur mais si guillaume me dire
combien cette loi on allait simplifier
dans l'agriculture et que les
agriculteurs saleh s'en trouver bien
mieux avec tous et cette simplification
or l'art déjà c'est quelque chose qui va
du 12 ans en cela parce que c'est des
déclarations supplémentaires aujourd'hui
dans toutes les exploitations agricoles
il y a les plans d'épandage avec toutes
les unités qui sont mises je crois qu'il
ya déjà suffisamment de travail qui est
fait de transparence encore obligé ses
déclarations chante en duo en première
lecture que c'était les prestataires
enfin ceux qui libre qui avait ses
déclarations mais compte ce n'est à mon
avis ça vaut de là et c'est pourquoi je
nous avons présenté cette suppression
des halles hier d'assises comme le
collègue lasserre vient aussi de les
défendre merci de nous confirmer merci
monsieur le sénateur amendement numéro
la présidente être pas si amendement
numéro 103 monsieur l'abbé excusez moi
donc je vais pas vous relire l'ensemble
de l'objet simplement vous dire qu'en
bretagne on est aux premières loges des
méfaits des excédents d'azoté que l'on
paye encore même s'il y a eu des
améliorations et des excédents divers de
de l'élevage excessivement intensifs
donc c'est pourquoi est il est pour nous
fondamentale a minima de rendre
systématique cette déclaration de flux
d'azoté dans les zones vulnérables
qui monsieur le sénateur en amendement
numéro 164 présentée par monsieur
guillaume a au nom de la commission des
affaires économiques
merci amendement numéro 53 monsieur le
noir oui mais là le président monsieur
mini cher collègue cet amendement est
tiré de la même tonne de cidre que les
amendements précédent en fait il s'agit
d'aller plus loin et de vérifier pour le
cas où cette disposition figurant dans
les amendements précédent qui ont été
défendus n'était pas adopté est-ce que
derrière le texte qui nous vient de
l'assemblée nationale il y aurait l'idée
que cette déclaration soit utilisé pour
ensuite effectuer des prélèvements
d'ordre fiscal en particulier ou à
travers des prélèvements parafiscaux au
détriment des agriculteurs
monsieur le sénateur avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur sur
ces cinq amendements à président donc
cinq amendements discussion commune qui
disent totalement l'inversé un
développement c'est le même thème donc
c'est normal qu'il soit en discussion
commune sur les deux premiers de
monsieur ben ali et de monsieur
lasserre je ne peux pas vous laisser
dire mais nous avons déjà eu ce débat je
ne peux pas vous laisser dire c'est des
contraintes supplémentaires pause
agriculteurs parce que ce n'est pas vrai
ce n'est pas vrai c'est pas non ce n'est
pas vrai c'est pas ce qui est écrit dans
la loi les agriculteurs sont obligés de
faire leurs démarches et n'inscrit d'un
plan d'épandage mais maintenant non mais
maintenant pas après cette loi
aujourd'hui bon simplement là ce qui est
dit dans le texte c'est ce sont les
fournisseurs ah oui mais ce ne sont pas
les agriculteurs vous avez dit on mais
des contraintes supplémentaires aux
aviculteurs ce n'est pas vrai ce sont
pour les fournisseurs c'est pas un
problème en soi me semble-t-il par
ailleurs cette mesure permettra de mieux
assurer le respect la directive nitrates
le ministre en parlera tout à l'heure
non mais la france peut être condamné on
peut on peut se ficher de l'europe etc
mais la france pourrait être condamné et
il vaut mieux assurer les choses je vous
dirai tout à l'heure comment on pourrait
ne pas être condamné sur le loup par
l'europe mais là dessus vous pourriez
être connaît donc les ministres va
donner ses argumentations je ne partage
pas votre argumentation ce dispositif ne
va pas dans le bon sens je crois mais
nous avons eu ce débat en première
lecture donc je donne deux avis
défavorables sur
monsieur l'abbé alors là c'est à
linverse c'est l'obligation pour le
préfet d'imposer la déclaration annuelle
de fuites d'azoté toujours par
pragmatisme et par souci d' équilibre je
n'y suis pas favorable et celui de
monsieur le noir que je connais trop
pour savoir que dans son intervention il
ne fait aucun procès d'intention
évidemment mais il est évidemment
voilà mais évidemment mais comme vous le
vous le dites dans votre amendement de
façon erronée pour qui une taxation fric
une loi donc on ne peut pas dire est ce
que l'assemblée voulait mettre une taxe
non c'est pas possible ce n'est pas dans
la dans la loi ce n'est pas dans le mode
à venir donc je pense que cet amendement
honnêtement maintenant qu'il a été
présenté et argumentée pourrait très
bien être retiré et si une nouvelle loi
devait amener une taxation nous dirions
ce que nous en pensons en tout cas s'il
n'est pas retirée moi j'ai émettraient
un avis un avis défavorable parce que
votre amendement présente pas d'intérêt
juridique
du gouvernement monsieur le ministre
merci madame la présidente oui on touche
à un sujet qui est très emblématique
quand même dans les débats de l'opinion
publique autour de l'agriculture et je
pense que chacun a compris ici que la
position du gouvernement était
parfaitement d'une part ciblé il s'agit
d'intervenir dans les territoires où il
ya des problèmes majeurs induits par les
flux d'azoté donc on ne pose pas le
problème d'un point de vue principe yale
théorique sur l'ensemble du territoire
national deuxièmement les choses se sont
ciblés correspondant sur un porte- le
rappeler à l'instant à une politique
aussi qu'ils aient entendu au plan
européen elle le fait dans le souci de
l'environnement ou à tous les sens du
terme est d'abord l'environnement des
agriculteurs concernés y at il une
surcharge de travail non c'est très
spécifiquement écrit dans la loi ce
n'est pas aux agriculteurs de faire
cette déclaration
y at il une taxe non c'est très
clairement qu'il n'y a absolument rien
sur ce sujet dans la loi et donc faire
des présupposés alors même que cette
assemblée aura si jamais la question se
pose et peut-être par une autre majorité
monsieur le sénateur et bien nous
verrions à ce moment là ce que dirait
l'assemblée nationale mais puisque vous
y pensez peut-être que vous pourriez
penser demain qui sait ah je vous
connais je vous ai connu aussi nous
étions ensemble donc si vous prêtez
parfois des reproches que vous faites à
d'autres je n'en sais rien
donc 1 nous voyons là en tout cas que
les propositions du texte de loi sont
parfaitement me semble-t-il équilibré
donc je donne un avis défavorable au nom
du gouvernement sur les trois
amendements qui ont été proposées et sur
l'avant droit seul amendement de la
commission avis favorable
bien je vais donc mettre aux voix ces
amendements d'abord les deux amendements
17 rectifié 52 qui sont identiques qui
ont reçu des avis défavorables de la
commission et du gouvernement qui et
pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient ces deux
amendements ne sont pas adopté
l'amendement numéro 103 deux avis
défavorables de la commission et du
gouvernement qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient cet amendement n'est pas
adopté un amendement de la commission
des affaires économiques 164 qui a reçu
un avis favorable du gouvernement qui
est pour
et qui est contre
cet amendement est adopté et enfin un
amendement numéro 53 qui a reçu deux
avis défavorables la commission et du
gouvernement
monsieur noir est ce que vous leur tirez
nord
non non je ne le retire jeu puisque vous
me donnez la parole madame la présidente
yeux la première volontiers
simplement j'ai pris acte avec vous tout
se sera vu en à l'officiel qui avait
absolument pas l'intention de la part de
ce gouvernement de procéder ensuite à
des prélèvements d'ordre fiscal ou
d'ordre parra fisc merci de ces
précisions le sénateur jeu mais on voit
cet amendement 53 qui et pour qui et
contre cet amendement n'est pas adopté
nous en venons à l'amendement numéro 102
toujours sur cet article quatre
monsieur l'abbé vous avez la parole pour
groupes écologistes oui madame la
ministre madame pardon madame la
présidente pas encore excusez moi
monsieur le ministre chers collègues
donc il s'agit de définir pour nous un
plafond maximal d'épandage annuel d'à
zone minérale et organique par hectare
en fonction des situations locales et de
leur évolution pour être pour être
précis parce que le seuil limite
existants 60 170 kg d'azoté par ha
représentent seulement la zot organique
donc ce que l'on souhaite c'est qu'il y
à un plafond pour le cumul et organiques
et minérales
seul sénateur à vie de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur madame la
présidente c'est un avis défavorable
pour des raisons très pratiques la
possibilité de définir une quantité
maximum d autres totale apportée par
hectare pour être intéressante notamment
dans les zones de marées vertes dans les
zones de forte pollution on sait que
c'est un vrai problème sauf que on sait
très bien que ce n'est pas possible de
faire la zone totale d'abord je vais
prendre mon papier d'abord il existe des
plafonds en matière d'azoté minéral sur
les cultures avant le 1er mars un kart
unités sur le blé et l'orge 80 unités
sur le colza et après le 1er mars sans
unité par hectare maximum donc il existe
déjà des plafonds mais pour l'azoté
minéral on ne peut pas le faire pour les
autres total et par ailleurs on sait
très bien que l'azoté minéral se fixent
mieux sur la plante que l'azoté
organique c'est la raison pour laquelle
sa part je pense d'une d'un intérêt mais
je vous demanderai de le retirer pour
des raisons pratiques et de faisabilité
si vous ne le retire y est pas
j'émettrais un avis défavorable parce
qu'il ya déjà des plafonds qui
s'applique
important avait du gouvernement monsieur
le ministre des forums
je vais mettre aux voix cet amendement
numéro 102 l'abbé vous savez la parole
après la demande de monsieur le
rapporteur est dans le cadre de la
cordialité de nos échanges je vais
retirer cet amendement
merci monsieur le sénateur je vous avais
toujours la parole pour l'amendement
numéro centre alors justement
il s'agit on revient donc au sujet de la
méthanisation
on a évoqué tout à l'heure l'exemple
allemand où des hectares de maïs des
milliers d'hectares de maïs sont
cultivées pour alimenter les
méthaniseurs la terre on a évoqué la
prose et la protection la préservation
de la terre de la terre agricole
communautaire qui doit être avant tout
nourricière 7 milliards d'habitants sur
la planète 9 milliards attendus en 2050
chaque chaque hectare au de terre
nourricière aura son importance alors
pour nous la met la méthanisation que
l'on reconnaît à sa juste valeur on tire
à ce que que l'alimentation en soit
limitée
uniquement à des déchets et des cultures
intermédiaires et quand même à titre
exceptionnel une dérogation à 7 à cette
interdiction peut être délivré dans des
conditions prévues par décret c'est un
amendement qui est extrêmement mesurer
et qui enrichit le texte je vous
remercie merci monsieur le sénateur avis
de la commission monsieur le rapporteur
gg je vais attendre l'avis du
gouvernement tout à l'heure mais je vous
demande un avis de retrait sinon
défavorable on a déjà examiné cet cet
amendement vous proposer de ne
reconnaître comme méthaniseur dans le
cadre des jus de ce que des
installations alimentées par des déchets
ou des cultures intermédiaires
on comprend bien une idée pas de soucis
ne pas encourager à produire par exemple
des céréales pour aller pour alimenter
directement des méthaniseurs au lieu de
contribuer à l'alimentation humaine nous
en avons parlé sauf que vous les voulez
éviter des dérives sauf que dans le
cadre de l'agrément des j2ee c'est pour
ça j'attends l'avis du
deux gouvernements l'égide de ce ne
serait pas
n'aurait pas l'agrément si c'était par
des cultures comme tel donc je pense que
votre amendement vous pouvez le retirer
après que le ministre vous et donnez
vous ai rassurés parce qu'il est de fait
satisfait évidemment si le gouvernement
à gré des j'ai eu 2 e à l'intérieur
desquels y aurait des méthaniseurs qui
serait alimenté par des cultures direct
je crois que ce serait à l'encontre de
ce que sont les génies 2e donc à mon
avis le gouvernement va vous rassurer
donc vous allez le retirer mais au cas
vous ne le retire y est pas j'émettrais
un avis défavorable et monsieur le
rapporteur à vis du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
merci mme la présidente
monsieur le sénateur nous partageons les
objectifs qui sont les autres néanmoins
nous ne pensons pas que nous puissions
accepter cet amendement
en fait la méthanisation agricole est
déjà très encadrée à la fois par
l'article 311 1 du code rural et par les
conditions de financement à ce stade les
méthaniseurs sont pour l'essentiel a
alimenté par des effluents de la
biomasse et des déchets de cultures
intermédiaires à vocation énergétique
il se peut que des ruptures puisse se
faire dans ces impressionnants aussi il
importe de ne pas s'interdire absolument
de compléter les apports par les
cultures aussi nous sommes les favoris
nous partageons votre philosophie mais
nous pensons que ce qui est dit dans
votre amendement est trop rigoureux et
peut entraîner des dysfonctionnements
aussi peut-être que là aussi après avoir
rappelé à travers votre amendement la
philosophie de ce système de
métallisation et bien
il pourrait être utile de le retirer
monsieur l'os merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur le sénateur
oui j'ai entendu mais à voir la grande
satisfaction de monsieur bizet
d'entendre le rapporteur sa main qui
était donc je vais maintenir cet
amendement
bien donc je vais m je vais mettre aux
voix cet amendement qui a reçu deux avis
défavorables
l'un de la commission l'autre du
gouvernement qui est pour cet amendement
qui est contre cet amendement n'est pas
adoptée nous en venons à 4 amendement
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
d'abord l'amendement numéro 54 c'est
monsieur bayer qu'il défend vous avez la
parole chers collègues
oui madame la présidente monsieur mini
chers collègues c'est un sujet sur les
les maux environnementaux
qui déjà beaucoup évoqué en première
lecture je crois l'avoir ebook est
également dans mon intervention hier
c'est vrai que pour nous il y encore un
certain nombre d'interrogations
c'est pourquoi nous pensons que là aussi
ce n'est pas de la simplification mais
que nous pouvons avoir des contraintes
ou des conflits qui puissent se passer
entre le propriétaire du terrain elles
preneur et c'est pourquoi cet amendement
propose de supprimer les alinéas de 9 à
6 même si déjà le bail environnemental
je voulais dire on a avancé quand même
danse
pendant dans des améliorations qu'elle
est dans le sens que nous souhaitions il
reste quand même aujourd'hui un certain
nombre d'interrogations
car en première lecture dont convient de
dire le sénat sous pli cette
généralisation les deux conditions
légales actuelles sont maintenues
une troisième est serré la troisième
condition permet d'insérer des clauses
environnementales
dans un bail pour pérenniser des
pratiques respectueuses de
l'environnement existantes et c'est vrai
que dans l'alinéa
11 on y trouve bien sûr la ressource en
eau la biodiversité alors la ressource
en eau chirec c'est tout naturel je
crois que là-dessus on va tous on va
tous se retrouver pour être d'accord ce
la biodiversité suivant comment on voit
les choses il peut y avoir des
différences très 3 1 pour quand vous le
savez mais aussi pour les paysages là
aussi on croit des interprétations
différence la qualité des produits on se
retrouve à may a aussi l'air alors là
aussi quelles appréciations qu'est ce
qu'on va demander au bail au bailleur
par rapport à la qualité de l'air
prévention des risques naturels
enfin il semble aussi qu on ouvre une
l'air peut faire une grande boîte de
pandore où il peut y avoir un petit peu
n'importe quoi qu'il soit mis dans des
exigences dans ses beaux
environnementaux alors c'est pourquoi
nous souhaitons que ces amendements
soient retirés bien sûr nous sommes
favorables lorsqu'il ya un accord entre
le bailleur et le preneur s'ils veulent
inclure des clauses d'un commun accord
il n'y a pas de problème mais quand je
rencontre aujourd'hui déjà un certain
nombre de personnes mais ce n'est pas du
lieu que la semaine dernière quelqu'un
qui me disait avoir aménagé 30 hectares
dans des parcelles en y faisant défaut c
est d avoir drainé et qu'aujourd'hui il
ne peut plus rien y faire et
qu'aujourd'hui c'est culte ces terrains
deviennent en grande difficulté eh bien
je crois aussi que là aussi quand on à
faire parfois aussi dans des
propriétaires qui peuvent être aussi un
petit peu intégriste ça nous amène à
quelques craintes alors c'est pourquoi
nous aurions souhaité que notre
assemblée nous supprimions ses alinéas
tout en gardant bien entendu la
possibilité comme je les dis à quelques
instants entrepreneurs et bailleurs
s'ils sont d'accord ensemble des maîtres
des clauses mais je crois que c'est fait
beaucoup trop large merci
merci madame la présidente mme merkel
avec cet amendement concerne le bail
environnemental et plus particulièrement
l'inclusion des clauses permettant la
préservation de la ressource en eau de
la bio diversité des paysages de la
qualité des produits des sols et de
l'air la prévention des risques naturels
et la lutte contre l'érosion
l'alinéa 11 de l'article 4 prévoit
l'inclusion de ces clauses
environnementales dans les beaux que ce
soit au moment de leurs conclusions ou
au moment de leur renouvellement cette
précision n'a pas de valeur juridique
car en droit le renouvellement d'un
contrat est équivalent à sa conclusion
est de plus si elle peut être incluse à
ces deux moments autant ne pas le prix 6
i très bien madame un ferrage je vais
vous demander de présenter aussi
l'amendement numéro 69 rectifié puisque
l'amendement 3 rectifié tombe oui tout à
fait madame la présidente et c'est à
travers cet amendement monsieur savary
souhaitait vraiment insister sur ce
point et dans le cas contraire à cet
assaut cette contractualisation
cela risquait d'être source de nombreux
contentieux dans la mesure où le preneur
ne pourrait pas faire évoluer son
système de production où ces pratiques
de gestion sans compromettre sur
l'exploitation si cela ne se faisait pas
à ce moment précis de la conclusion du
baril merci madame la sénatrice
l'avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur sur ces trois amendements
oui alors bon mais moi je voudrais dire
à monsieur bailly qu à première lecture
nous avions trouvé une position de
compromis nous avions modifié le texte
du gouvernement le texte de l'assemblée
et je propose que nous en restions là
parce que nous étions d'accord sur la
formulation prix en lecture du bail
environnemental tels que nous avions mis
les garde-fous et là maintenant vous
sied tout à fait votre droit évidemment
vous revenez là dessus en disant
supprime les envier les alinéas donc on
supprime le bail environnemental
non je ne suis pas favorable je crois
pas qu'il faille le faire l'équilibrage
matic nous avions trouvé mal et m'allait
très bien donc je mets un avis
défavorable sur l'article 25 rectifié
jeu l'amendement pardon merci monsieur
le président de la commission
l'amendement 25 rectifié j'ai mieux aimé
un avis favorable
je crois que c'est du bon sens la
lecture la rédaction de l'assemblée
nationale nous semble un peu
superfétatoire
le renouvellement de bail et un nouveau
bail donc la précision apportée par les
députés n'amène pas donc je suis plutôt
favorable quant aux 69 rict de 40 69 ans
le 3 est tombé le 69 rectifier si comme
je l'espère nous votons l'amendement 25
rectifier le 69 rectifié tombera donc je
demande de ce serait
2 euros
et après
à vis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
merci madame la présidente nous sommes
défavorable à l'amendement numéro 54 on
a déjà eu l'occasion de le dire en
première lecture je ne pense pas qu'il y
ait de rupture milhas au contraire
favoriser des évolutions positives dans
les sens des intérêts des deux parties
et par contre nous en mettrons à sagesse
du sénat s'agissant de l'amendement 25
rectifier merci monsieur le ministre je
vais donc mettre aux voix c'est
amendement l'amendement numéro 54 qui a
reçu deux avis défavorables de la
commission et du gouvernement qui et
pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient cet amendement n'est pas
adopté l'amendement numéro 25 rectifié
qui a reçu un avis favorable la
commission un avis de sagesse en fin
d'assemblée de la part du gouvernement
qui et pour
qui et contre cet amendement est adopté
et donc l'amendement 69 rectifié tombe
vous êtes d'accord mansehra nous passons
à deux amendements en discussion commune
toujours sur l'article 4 l'amendement
numéro 59 monsieur bailly
et madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je crois que c'est uniquement
pour préciser les choses remplacer les
molettes recommandé par actuelle avec
accusé de réception par les mots à extra
judiciaires afin de limiter les
contentieux de pur formalisme et
l'indispensable de déterminer le moyens
par lesquels le preneur doit notifier sa
demande au propriétaire lac
extrajudiciaires le moyen déjà utilisée
par le propriétaire pour notifier son
congé aux fermiers il ya pour avantage
de ne pas causer d'ambiguïté sur la date
qui doit être prise en considération
pour le point de départ de la
prescription
contrairement une lettre recommandée
avec avis de réception donc il nous
semblait que c'était pour aller dans un
sens de que et d'éviter des contentieux
laisse à l'appréciation de notre
assemblée
simulator amendement du gouvernement
numéro 160 monsieur le ministre
répondrait aussi et bien absolument
merci donc l'amendement 161 amendements
de précision qui permet aux
propriétaires de pouvoir apprécier en
toute connaissance de cause si le coc
preneur restant rempli les conditions
lui permettant de reprendre le bail à
son seul nom et de saisir le tribunal
paritaire des baux ruraux en temps
utiles s'ils l'estiment opportun l'ajout
d'un formalisme minimum sécurisé la
situation du bailleur le délai de
saisine du tp br de nature réglementaire
sera précisé par décret il s'agit donc
d'un aliment l' amendement de
clarification alors s'agissant de
l'amendement 59 pour tout vous dire le
seul sénateur nous pensons exactement le
contraire
c'est tout à fait d'ailleurs
l'esprit dans lequel s'est exprimé le
ministre de l'économie
monsieur montebourg et avant lui de
nombreux rapports et singulièrement
celui de la cour des comptes et de
l'inspection générale des finances qui
nous apprend qu'il y a aujourd'hui un
certain nombre d'actes ou de procédure
qui coûte très cher à nos compatriotes
en l'occurrence en espèces et c'est donc
les agriculteurs qui seraient amenés à
payer un acte d'huissier qui quelque
part serait de la aux alentours de 15
cents euros au lieu d'une lettre
recommandée de 4 euros cinq ans avouez
que vous qui était attaché bien sûr vous
l'avez souvent dit mais là je ne
comprends pas bien alors à moins que
évidemment il se soit le résultat cet
amendement d'une sollicitation d'une
profession et là quelle profession fait
la démonstration à travers cet
amendement que finalement des actes
simples pourraient être existé sans
qu'il y ait forcément des procédures du
huissier de justice donc cela me semble
inopportun pour la profession est
inopportun pour les agriculteurs que
d'avoir à accepter cet amendement merci
monsieur le ministre j'ai quand même
demandé l'avis de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur sur ces deux amendements
la commission c'est favorable à celui du
gouvernement donc de fait celui de
monsieur bailly sera soit retiré soit
n'a plus de raison d'être mais
franchement le fait de faire payer les
agriculteurs avec l'acte comme saad 1000
ou 1500 euros alors qu'un simple timbre
et une lettre recommandée suffit à mon
avis je pense que enfin moi je vous
demande de le retirer tout cas avis
favorable sur le gouvernement mais comme
le vote passe avant
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
bizet vous avez la parole
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre chers collègues monsieur lui
vous avez raison il ya une différence de
coût et qui est très claire entre une
lettre recommandée une prestation d'un
huissier si vous voulez mais je crois
qu'il faut regarder également cela au
travers du risque beaucoup plus élevé
qui serait celui d'un contentieux pour
une non précision précisément de la
réception d'une décision travers d'une
lettre recommandée je crois que l'objet
de cet amendement ce n'est pas de
défense de défendre une profession
l'objet de cet amendement c'est de
clarifier précisément un risque de
contentieux qui peut exister au travers
d'une délivrance d'une lettre
recommandée que par hypothèse on voit ça
quand même assez facilement
ok
par monsieur bailly retirer votre
amendement comme on vous y a incité
oui avec les précisions gardanne et
monsieur le ministre on va jouer leur
phase est tellement collé que césar
puisqu'il a eu certaines exemple
justement de contentieux sur ces sujets
là qui avaient été posés cet amendement
qu'il me semblait qu'il ne semblait
justifier mais fort des arguments qui
ont été
développées je retire l'amendement merci
monsieur le sénateur je vais donc mettre
aux voix l'amendement numéro 160 du
gouvernement qui a reçu un avis
favorable de la commission qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient cet
amendement est adopté
deux amendements identiques faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune le
numéro 23 madame serra merci madame la
présidente mes chers collègues ces
dispositions prévues par le projet de
loi viennent bouleverser les
dispositions régissant aujourd'hui la
mise à disposition des baux en effet la
mise à disposition ou l'apport de droit
au bail ne peut se faire qu'au profit
d'une société à objet principalement
agricoles or le projet de loi vient
étendre le régime de la mise à
disposition à toute personne morale à
vocation principalement agricoles cette
disposition introduite en première
lecture à l'assemblée nationale a été
supprimée par le sénat compte tenu de
l'insécurité juridique qu'elle engendre
puisqu'elle ouvre le champ aux
association de loi 1901 aux sociétés
coopératives etc de nombreux schémas de
mise à disposition ou d'apport dubai
pourrait l'en se développer au profit de
sociétés l'ont exploitante en
contradiction totale avec les
dispositions du statut du fermage qui
prévoit l'exploitation effective et
personnels du bien loué au sein même de
la société bénéficiaire de la mise à
disposition d'une part celle ci est une
atteinte à la liberté d'exploitation du
preneur dans le sens où il n'a pas
nécessairement dans la structure
bénéficiaire de la mise à disposition le
pouvoir d'orienter l'activité agricole
et d'autre part des sous-locations
formellement prohibé par le statut du
fermage d'ordre public pourrait se
généraliser
généralisée sans contrôle
cette disposition des manants ni d'une
demande de la profession ni de la
propriété devrait être retirée contenu
de la sécurité juridique qu'elle
instaure si madame la sénatrice
l'amendement numéro 145 monsieur colin
vous avez la maladie nous ce ministére
collègues effectivement ça vient d'être
rappelé en première lecture nos
collègues députés avaient l'argile les
possibilités de mise à disposition par
le preneur du bail rural dont il est
titulaire à toute personne morale à
vocation principalement agricoles et
donc plus exclusivement aux groupements
agricoles aux sociétés civiles
d'exploitation est donc autorisée dans
ces nouvelles conditions le portage
opérations d'installation d'agriculteurs
risquait de créer une insécurité
juridique en permettant par exemple les
s'était rappelé aussi des sous locations
normalement interdite faut-il le
rappeler par le statut du fermage et
dans sa sagesse c'est bien connu le
sénat avait supprimé cette disposition
et vous aviez monsieur le rapporteur
d'ailleurs souligné à cette occasion que
la modification introduite à l'article
411 38 du code rural faisait sauter les
contreparties exigées des propriétaires
l'assemblée a rétabli l'article certes
en instaurant quelques gardes néanmoins
pourquoi maintenir ce dispositif qui
fragilise l'équilibré entre bailleur et
preneur alors que le code rural prévoit
déjà des mises à disposition rien ne
démontre que les règles actuelles ne
suffisent pas et c'est pourquoi nous
proposons les aliénas que les alinéas
concernés à cet article 96 de rendement
pour présenter merci monsieur le
sénateur avis de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur
sur ces deux amendements 23 ans qui fit
140 5 madame la présidente
je vais demander à madame ferrat et à
monsieur
colin de retirer ces deux amendements et
s'il ne les retiraient pas j'émettrais
un avis défavorable pourquoi ce que vous
l'avez non vous l'avez très bien dit
l'un et l'autre
l'assemblée en première lecture vais me
un texte ce texte n'était pas à notre
sens assez performant nous y sommes donc
revenu dessus et nous avons bien fait
c'est ça l'intérêt des deux lectures
parce que nous améliorons les textes et
en fonction de ce que nous avions dit en
deuxième lecture à l'assemblée nationale
les députés sont allés au delà de ce que
nous faisions et on ya deux garde-fous
la mise à disposition du bail rural je
vais d'élire le bénéficiaire de la mise
à disposition doit être une personne
morale à objets agricoles la terre l'eau
et restera donc à objets à usage
agricole d'un premier garde-fous et le
deuxième en tout état de cause l'accord
du bailleur et requis la mise à
disposition du bail ne pourra pas se
faire dans son dos il s'agit donc là
d'une ouverture tout à fait maîtrisée me
semble-t-il et je pense que nous
pourrions prendre le risque de
l'innovation en ayant bien encadré cette
innovation qui permettra de développer
les initiatives d'associations et
organismes qui cherchent à alléger le
poids financier de l'acquisition
foncière qui pèse beaucoup sur les
aviculteurs aussi je vous demanderai à
l'une et à l'autre de bien vouloir
retirer votre amendement sans ça je me
verrais contraint à regret d'émettre un
avis défavorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur à vis du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre mais
ma vie même avis rentrée ou avis
défavorable alors mes chers collègues
mam fait rare vous retirer et monsieur
collarin ces deux amendements sont
retirés nous abordons 4 amendement
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
le 22 rectifié malam ferrat
merci madame la présidente mes chers
collègues nous ne comprenons pas
pourquoi ces alinéas sont apparus à
l'assemblée nationale à l'initiative du
gouvernement sans concertation il vise à
réformer le mode de désignation des
assesseurs aux tribunaux paritaires des
baux ruraux par cette mesure la
désignation des assesseurs sera réalisé
par le juge sur une liste établie par le
préfet sur la base des propositions
formulées par les organisations
syndicales représentatives et les
fédérations de bailleurs ce mécanisme
semble à la fois complexe et injuste les
assesseurs sont jusqu'à présent élus
tous les six ans et siège aux côtés du
président du tribunal d'instance ces
tribunaux composé d'un magistrat
professionnel et de représentants élus
par les bailleurs et les honneur
permettent une bonne administration de
la justice dans une réglementation
complexe et reposant sur des situations
qui nécessitent de bien connaître
l'activité agricole sur la forme cette
manière de procéder est inacceptable
alors que des groupes de travail se sont
tenues sur l'évolution des tribunaux
voilà plus de deux ans et qu aucune
rencontre n'a eu lieu depuis le
gouvernement a proposé une réforme
fondamentale des tribunaux paritaires
sans aucune concertation préalable
sur le fond une telle modification aura
pour effet de remplacer les actuels
magistrat reconnues pour leur compétence
et surtout élus par leurs pairs par des
personnes proposées par les
organisations syndicales représentatives
figurant sur une liste dans laquelle
juste professionnel devra choisir en
toute indépendance quand bien même les
candidats actuels peuvent faire mention
d'une appartenance syndicale lors des
élections ils sont élus par les
agriculteurs et propriétaires pour leur
compétence et non sur la base d'une
étiquette dans le dispositif électoral
actuel les candidats assesseurs
souhaitant se revendiquer d'un autre
syndicat peuvent le faire mais dans tous
les cas l'appartenance syndicale c'est
le permet notamment la formation
continue des assesseurs n'est pas un
gage de compétence le mécanisme de
désignation proposé ne peut qu'aboutir à
une politisation préjudiciable à une
bonne administration de la justice dans
les tribunaux paritaires pourtant
reconnue tant par les juges que par les
bailleurs ou preneur pour son efficience
trice monsieur bailly pour l'amendement
62 rectifié qui est identique
il est exactement le même que celui que
vient de défendre notre collègue madame
ses rames ce colloque un jeu mais je
veux quand même dire ici que je regrette
vraiment que le gouvernement n'ait pas
proposé
cet amendement en première lecture parce
que c'est vrai qu'il ya un vrai débat
moi je suis j'ai suivi un petit peu ça
dans ma vie professionnelle
et c'est vrai que c'est assez complexe
aujourd'hui les
ces élections aux tribunaux paritaires
c'est vrai que collège des bailleurs le
collège des preneurs c'est une
complexité donc ça me sort est méritée
je crois une vraie discussion parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est arrivé à
l'assemblée nationale et vu le temps qui
nous est imparti je répète encore entre
le temps de l'assemblée nationale est le
temps qu'on nous sommes aujourd'hui
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas pu beaucoup
l'évoqué sur le terrain avec les
organismes agricoles et on parle des
organisations syndicales mais moi je
suis plus si vous voulez chambre
d'agriculture puisque c'est quand même
elle représente en leur sein vu leurs
compositions les collèges des
exploitants il ya des propriétaires il
ya des salariés tout le monde et aux
chambres d'agriculture
donc pourquoi aussi ne viendrait pas des
chambres d'agriculture pourquoi les
organisations syndicales avec tous les
problèmes que cela va poser alors moi je
pense qu'ils avaient besoin d'une
réflexion sur ce sujet là je pense qu'il
fallait faire l'étude d'impact c'est
peut-être pas le terme qui convient mais
aussi combien aujourd'hui tout est ce
mécanisme des élections beau paritaire
alors on nous demande d'approuver cet
amendement du gouvernement dans la
précipitation et c'est ça que je
regrette et que c'est pourquoi nous
disions qu'aujourd'hui c'était peut-être
fallait continuer la réflexion mais en
attendent vraiment de savoir s'il aura
pas des problèmes tels que c'est prévu
en attente on pensait qu'il fallait
supprimer ces années-là de 28 à 43 qui
sont arrivés à notre connaissance comme
il ya que très très peu de jours merci
monsieur le sénateur amendement numéro
144 identique également monsieur colin
oui a rappelé qu'en seconde lecture à
l'assemblée nationale nos collègues
députés ont décidé ça vient d'être
appelé sur proposition du gouvernement
d'ailleurs de mettre fin à l'élection
des assesseurs des tribunaux paritaires
des baux ruraux pour proposer une
nouvelle procédure de désignation des
assesseurs représentant d'un côté les
propriétaires de l'autre côté les
preneurs d arguments ont été avancés ont
été rappelés le faible taux de
participation à cette élection le coût
de l'organisation
on peut être entendre ces raisons
m'introduire cette réforme sans avoir
mené la concertation nécessaire et peut
être prématuré
et la profession ne s'en est ému en
commission il a été reconnu comme
modifier les mécanismes de l'élection
des associations lecture était peut-être
pardonnez moi l'expression mais un peu
cavalier et c'est le premier point
ensuite la politisation de cette
élection pourrait perturber la bonne
administration de la justice dans les
tribunaux paritaires qui ne pose pas de
problème dans son organisation actuelle
l'appartenance syndicale n'est pas un
obstacle pour ses jets actuellement aux
côtés du président du tribunal
d'instance la rendre obligatoire et donc
superflu et rien ne garantit collection
sera plus attractive même dans un cadre
pluraliste donc afin de permettre le
temps de la réflexion nous proposons
comme des précédents orateurs de
supprimer les alinéas introduisant la
nouvelle procédure de désignation des
assesseurs c'est le sens de cet
amendement si monsieur le sénateur
amendement numéro 150 de monsieur le
ministre
oui
merci madame la présidente si vous le
permettez je dirais à la fois ma
position sur les autres amendements et
je défendrai l'amendement du
gouvernement
pour dire tout simplement que la
question est maintenant connue savait
que la procédure de désignation des
assesseurs des tribunaux paritaires des
baux ruraux a montré d'un certain point
de vue son inefficacité
puisque à la fois elle a abouti à ce que
en 2010
n'a pas permis la constitution de 18 des
tribunaux l'encaissé deuxièmement elle a
un coût et vit dans une préoccupation un
coût financier posiez la question
monsieur le sénateur d'après ce que je
crois savoir elle est aux alentours de 4
à 5 millions d'euros ce qui n'est pas
négligeable dans la situation où nous
sommes et donc il y a eu cette prise un
amendement gouvernemental qui a été
débattue à l'assemblée nationale
et aujourd'hui nous pouvons présenter un
nouvel amendement qui nous le pensons a
tenu compte à la fois des débats qui ont
eu lieu aussi bien au sénat qu'à
l'assemblée et qui ont été discuté aussi
avec les organisations professionnelles
et ils nous pouvons penser que
aujourd'hui la proposition que nous
faisons a le soutien des organisations
professionnelles
alors cet amendement il vise tout
simplement à préciser le mode de
désignation de ces tribunaux paritaires
en précisant plus clairement les
modalités de propositions des
représentants des preneurs par les
opéras représentative et des bailleurs
par les opéras aussi représentative mais
aussi la fédération départementale des
propriétaires privés ruraux il indique
également que c'est le premier président
de la cour d'appel qui procède à la
nomination des assesseurs après avis du
président voilà nous pensons que ces
modifications sont de nature à
privilégier les candidats les plus
compétents tout en tenant compte des
remarques je les dis de ce qui s'est
passé à
l'assemblée
en prenant aussi en compte les remarques
des opéras disposant actuellement du
plus grand nombre d'assesseurs et je
crois que nous sommes arrivés à un
compromis
d'efficacité de transparence de
représentativité et qu'il serait bon que
le travail qui est fait aujourd'hui par
le gouvernement soient reconnus sur
l'ensemble des bancs du sénat
merci monsieur le ministre je vais
demander l'avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur sur cet
amendement et sur les trois identique si
madame la présidente je propose que
l'ensemble de ces bons reconnaissent
l'avancée du gouvernement évoque son
amendement même si évidemment nous
aurions cet amendement aurait pu ne pas
être présenté à l'assemblée nationale en
deuxième lecture enfin il l'est monsieur
bailly donc il l'est il avance et là
c'est le mouvement le gouvernement
souhaitait avancer sur la désignation
des pour les tribunaux donc moi je suis
favorable à l'amendement du gouvernement
défavorable aux autres une telle
solution ça existe déjà
dans les tribunaux des affaires de la
sécurité sociale et ça marche c'est de
l'efficacité c'est du gain d'argent tout
le monde s'y retrouve donc j'ai mis à
nager mais un avis défavorable pour
courtrai pour les trois amendements et
un avis favorable pour celui du du
gouvernement qui encadre qui permet un
peu mieux de d'améliorer les choses et
monsieur le rapporteur donc monsieur
monsieur le ministre a donné son avis
sur ces trois amendements je vais doctor
donner la parole à bosser deneux
huit mois je ne partage pas du tout
l'avis du gouvernement je ne comprends
pas que ce soit une avancée c'est un
recul quand on passe d'un système où on
vote qui implique des conditions
démocratiques qu on fonctionnait depuis
70 ans et qu'on dit maintenant on va les
désigner c'est une avancée c'est même
assez incompréhensible et je voudrais
vous dire monsieur le ministre c'est pas
parce que dans dix huit endroits si on
les analyse un par un ce sont les
endroits où de fermage est peu répandu
pour des raisons locales dans tous les
départements où fermage est important
voire dominant les tribunaux paritaires
donne totalement satisfaction il est
incompréhensible que cette affaire
vienne par ce gouvernement aujourd'hui
nous serons forcément compte les avis de
ce gouvernement
merci monsieur bailly
madame la présidente explications de
vote
j'ai bien entendu les réponses de manger
le ministre et c'est vrai que je les dis
d'un peu de moins d'intervention tout à
l'heure j'ai des interrogations
c'est un petit peu dommage qu'on n'en
parle pas plus longtemps mais j'aurai
une question précise on parle des
organisations syndicales donc ça veut
dire que les chambres d'agriculture dont
il ya des élections là vraiment tous les
agriculteurs les propriétaires quand il
ya les renouvellements des chambres
d'agriculture tout le monde et puis je
crois que le taux de participation est
encore plus important que dans toutes
les chambres consulaires et dans
beaucoup d'ingrédients professionnel et
je dois savoir la raison pour qu'on a
retenu plus les organisations syndicales
que les chambres d'agriculture qui sont
représentatives et qui représentent
l'ensemble pour faire les propositions
justement de ses juges c'était ça ma
question
ensuite bien sûr il y aura le veau tel
que vous l'avez souhaité merci monsieur
le sénateur monsieur le président
guillaume vous m'avez demandé la parole
six ans marcel deneux il s'agit pas de
supprimer des tribunaux ils sont pas
supprimés ils continueront
ils continueront à exister il s'agit de
moderniser d'affaires vous avez combien
de participation à ces élections
vous savez comme et d'abstention dans
ces élections 80% d'abstention donc il
s'agit d'être un peu plus efficace il
s'agit de faire en sorte on aurait pu ne
pas l'aborder d'adam dans ce texte mais
je pense que l'amendement du
gouvernement permet d'aller de l'avant
permet d'innover permet un peu de
moderniser c'est pas à bouger pour
bouger mais moi je pense pas que ça pose
de deux problèmes de problème
particulier c'est aujourd'hui c'est
comme ça la sécurité sociale qui pensent
que ça ne fonctionne pas pour les
tribunaux de la sécurité sociale et
quels problèmes cela pose sans pause pas
n'aura peut-être pas perdre passer un
quart d'heure sur un entonnoir mais je
pense que nous pouvons passer au vote
merci monsieur le rapporteur
donc je mets on vote d'abord les trois
amendements 22 62 46 ans 44 qui ont reçu
deux avis défavorables
qui est pour
et qui est contre
ces trois amendements ne sont pas
adoptées amendement numéro 152 du
gouvernement qui a reçu un avis
favorable de la commission qui et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient
cet amendement est adopté je met en voix
l'article 4 de ce projet de loi qui est
pour
et qui est contre
cet article iv est adopté
je mets au voile article 4 bis aa
je vais commencer par vous faire voter
qui et pour qui est contre donc il est
adopté article 4 bis ab même vote
article 4 bis à ces mêmes votes
alors l'article 4 bis à a été supprimé
il le demeure
article 4 bis même vote
nous en arrivons à l'article 4 ter à
avec un amendement numéro 28 présenté
par madame ferrat merci monsieur le
président madame la présidente je vous
propose de rétablir cet article dans la
rédaction issue de nos débats de
première lecture l'assemblée nationale
l'a malheureusement supprimer le droit
du métayer d'obtenir automatiquement la
conversion du métayage en fermage sous
la seule condition d'une antériorité de
8 ans est de nature à dissuader les
propriétaires de conclure un bail à
métayage il compromet la sécurité
juridique des montages de portage
foncier fondé sur l'économie du bail à
métayage ce droit est rarement mise en
oeuvre au bénéfice des exploitants ils
constituent une menace permanente pour
les propriétaires et joue en définitive
le plus souvent à l'encontre des
exploitants en dissuadant les
investisseurs et en orientant les
propriétaires vers des solutions
alternatives au bail telles que
l'exploitation en prestation de service
c'est pourquoi cet amendement proposait
supprime simplement ce droit de
conversion automatique
et un madame la sénatrice avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
la présidente s'agit de la suppression
de la conversion de plein droit du bail
à métayage à bail à ferme l'article 4
117 ans du code rural madame et de la
pêche maritime permet de convertir tout
bail à métayage en bail à ferme à
l'expiration de chaque année culture à
la portée de la troisième année du bail
initial cette conversion intervient soit
au choix du preneur soit au choix du
bailleur elle ne peut pas être refusée
lorsque le métayer la demande après huit
années l'amendement propose de supprimer
cette conversion de plein droit sur
demande du métayer à échéance de 8
années cet amendement avait été adopté
par le sénat en première lecture il ne
concerne que la viticulture que la
multiculture or si l'on peut comprendre
que le propriétaire soit mécontent de la
situation d'incertitude que cela crée la
modification de la loi sur ce point
contribuerait à modifier les équilibres
économiques de nombreuses régions
viticoles ou le bail à métayage est
encore utilisé et il est dans beaucoup
d'endroits l'adoption par le sénat de
cet article a d'ailleurs fait l'objet de
quelques contestations c'est dans un
langage fleuri ce qui montre qu'il n'y a
pas de consensus sur le sujet c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'émets un avis
défavorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur à vis du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
mais ma vie mais la présidente à
l'évidence
la france est riche de terroir divers et
finalement ce que nous avons vécu dans
la discussion sur la carte des régions
nous le voyons aussi peut-être à travers
cet amendement il n'ya pas c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire unanimité madame
sénateurs dans
l'idée qu'ils que vous avez avancé donc
nous préférons évidemment qu'elle ne
soit pas reprise merci monsieur le
ministre madame ferrat oui merci madame
la présidente c'est vrai et vous l'avez
dit monsieur le rapporteur cela touche
essentiellement la viticulture et
particulièrement la viticulture
champenoise nous sommes en ce moment
sous cette complexité ou certains
propriétaires n'ayant plus les moyens de
faire exploiter se voir récupérer entre
guillemets par des jeunes eux c'est
comme on dire des exploitations où des
des maisons de champagne de grande
importance qui assurant des prestations
de services avec une facilité
déconcertante
voit échapper sans doute à de plus
jeunes exploitants la possibilité de
mettre en oeuvre
une entreprise de qualité voilà c'était
le sens de cet amendement je comprends
que l'unanimité n'étant pas là pas même
une majorité je suis obligé de le
retirer mais je vous avoue que je le
retiens la mort dans l'âme je ne réponds
pas à un vrai besoin et à des
difficultés et à des des personnes qui
s'engouffrent dans cette brèche profite
je n'ai pas peur de le dire du système
merci madame la sénatrice donc cet
amendement numéro 28 est retiré et
l'article 4 ter à n'est pas rétabli nous
passons à l'article 4 qu'un pièce avec
un amendement 29 rectifié toujours
madame ferrat je ne m'en lasse pas
madame la présidente
merci mes chers collègues il s'agit là
encore de rétablir un article que nous
avions adopté en première lecture aux
commissions et qu'ils n'avaient pas été
modifiées par notre assemblée c'est une
question d'harmonisation normative entre
le régime du bail cessible et celle du
bail rural d'usagé commun actuellement
renouvelé pour une période de cinq ans
il est proposé de le renouveler pour
neuf ans tel que le prévoit l'article l
411 50 du code rural
applicables au bail classique cet
amendement vise à plus de cohérence dans
le code rural si madame la sénatrice
pour la commission avis du rapporteur
de la commission donne un avis favorable
merci monsieur le ministre sagesse
un point devant
bien je mets donc cet amendement 29
rectifié aux voix il a reçu un avis
favorable de la commission et david
saint chef du gouvernement qui est pour
et qui est contre
belle unanimité donc cet amendement est
adopté et donc je mets au voile article
cas donc l'article 4 pièces est rétabli
merci voilà un article 5 qui est pour
et qui est contre
il est adopté article 6 même vote
article 7 je suis saisi d'un amendement
du rapporteur monsieur le président
guillaume au nom de la commission
l'ordination dans la poésie merci à vis
du gouvernement
rome très bien je mets envoie cet
article 165 cet amendement au pardon
même si le président de la commission
m'a pas rappelée à l'ordre donc cet
amendement numéro 165 qui est pour
et qui est contre
il est adopté un amendement numéro 35
défendu par monsieur le cam 1 la
présidente ce mini chers collègues oui
en première lecture au sénat avait
adopté à l'article 7 du projet de loi un
alinéa visant à interdire les rabais
remises et ristournes pour les produits
alimentaires figurant sur une liste
établie par décret nous étions convenus
que ces pratiques commerciales présenter
les inconvénients majeurs pour les
producteurs qui était dans un rapport de
force extrêmement défavorable la
commission des affaires économiques de
l'assemblée nationale a supprimé cet
ajout c'est pourquoi nous vous le
présentons à nouveau en espérant qu'il
ait un sort aussi heureux qu'au sénat la
dernière fois
merci avis de la commission c'est le
rapporteur
je donnerai un avis de jeu demande
l'avis du gouvernement pardon
alors à vis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre merci mme la présidente
l'avis du gouvernement et circonstanciée
mais il se conclut de façon défavorable
sur le sénat les dispositions de
l'article
441 2 1 prévoit pour les produits
entrant dans son champ d'application des
relations contractuelles formalisé
différente du contrat elle émeut avec
convention unique pour ses produits la
formalisation de la relation commerciale
est réduite et ne concerne donc plus que
certaines dispositions telles que les
remises des rabais des ristournes la
modification proposée monsieur le
sénateur et en ses dispositions
particulières qui prévoit une
formalisation des relations simplifiée
par rapport au contrat elle émeut
aujourd'hui applicables à une liste
limitée de produits agricoles de
produits de la pêche et de l'agriculture
a potentiellement tout produit
alimentaire
elle conduit de fait à modifier la
relation contractuelle sans aucune étude
d'impact préalable
elle a pour effet de limiter la
formalisation de l'encadrement des
engagements réciproques entre
fournisseurs et clients alors même que
cette formalisation et protectrice des
fournisseurs en effet elle assure une
certaine transparence des relations
entre fournisseurs distributeurs elle
permet de garantir un certain équilibre
des relations notamment ce qui concerne
les réductions de prix les modalités de
la coopération commerciale ainsi que les
autres obligations et donc il serait
illusoire de penser que compte tenu de
certaines difficultés rencontrées dans
l'application des contrats lme et vous
avez raison de ce point de vue il serait
plus protecteur d'avoir une
formalisation réduite que de la relation
commerciale donc nous sommes dans ces
conditions nous ne sommes pas prêts à
accepter cette prise de risque
supplémentaire qu'elles que soient
parfois les insatisfactions que l'on
peut avoir sur la situation actuelle
d'où l'aspect est défavorable à votre
moment où je le sais date merci monsieur
le ministre je mets aux voix cet
amendement numéro 35 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable du gouvernement
mais c'est de ne vous avez la parole
que je je comprends mal la position du
gouvernement par rapport à ce que nous
entendons en permanence dans des
déclarations philosophe verbale c'est
vrai il faut maîtriser la relation entre
la grande distribution et fournisseurs
il faut défendre les producteurs mais la
frilosité du gouvernement est telle
qu'on ne fait rien et que quand par
hasard il ya un essai d'avancé le
gouvernement recule il est clair que
dans cette affaire le gouvernement n'est
pas cohérent donc nous voterons compte
merci monsieur donne au jeu mais on voit
donc cet amendement numéro 35
qui est pour
alors qui est pour
et qui est contre
cet amendement est adopté
un amendement numéro 34
oui madame la présidente dans le droit
fil du précédent le célèbre coefficient
multiplicateur qui je le rappelle a été
votée ici au sénat ya quelques années
sous l'impulsion de notre ami daniel
soulage du lot et ancien sénateur du lot
et garonne alors nous avons présentées
en donc cet amendement en première
lecture nous sommes en effet importants
comme je les dis dans la discussion
générale de faire des propositions afin
de garantir aux agriculteurs une juste
rémunération de leur travail il faut
dans ce cas d'assurer un juste prix
toutes les idées sont bonnes à prendre
pour essayer de rétablir une plus juste
répartition de la valeur ajoutée sur
l'ensemble de la chaîne de production et
de commercialisation agricole la réunion
qui a eu lieu liège a été très
instructive sur les différentes
possibilités envisagées ainsi serge
papin propose d'amender la lme en fixant
des niveaux de vente minimum au dessus
du seuil de revente à perte le
coefficient multiplicateur est une autre
des mesures possibles en période de
crise conjoncturelle tel que défini à
l'article l 611 4 du code rural et de la
pêche maritime ou en prévision de la
survenue d'une telle crise les ministres
compétents peuvent décider de
l'application d'un coefficient
multiplicateur
entre le prix d'achat et le prix de
vente des fruits et légumes périssables
à un taux et pour une durée qu'ils
définissent celle ci ne pouvant excéder
trois mois les mêmes établissent la
liste précise des produits visés par
cette mesure par notamment nous
élargissons le champ d'application de
cette mesure aux produits agricoles
périssables
sachant que la mise en oeuvre du
dispositif restent entre les mains du
pouvoir réglementaire qui nous semble
que c'etait large issement est tout à
fait raisonnable
nous savons monsieur le rapporteur que
vous avez changé d'avis depuis 2010 sur
l'opportunité d'une telle mesure
cependant nous ne pensons pas que
l'argument tiré de l'absence de moyens
de contrôles administratifs des prix que
vous avez développé en première lecture
soit une raison à renoncer à une telle
mesure vous nous avez exprimé également
votre crainte de la tentation de
s'approvisionner hors de nos frontières
pour maintenir des prix bas pour le
consommateur vous avez raison ce risque
existe il s'accentuera pour d'autres
productions comme la viande avec le
traité de libre-échange 30
transatlantique donc nous considérons
pour notre part que le coefficient
multiplicateur reste une bonne mesure
nous vous demandons donc d'abord
d'adopter cet amendement tout en ne
fermant la porte à aucun progrès qui
puisse permettre des prix rémunérateurs
à l'ensemble du monde agricole
merci monsieur le sénateur avis de la
commission monsieur leur apportant
la présidente cher gérard leucan je ne
pense pas qu'il faille en rajouter je
donne un avis défavorable
ce débat est récurrent nous le portons
depuis des décennies je m'étais laissé
convaincre dans les années 90 du
bienfait du coup c'est un multiplicateur
et je les défends du temps que j'ai pu
et je me suis aperçu que malheureusement
ça ne fonctionnait pas donc par principe
de réalité
j'écris mais un avis défavorable
si monsieur le rapporteur à vis du
gouvernement
on voit bien que le coefficient
multiplicateur peut jouer sur des
produits frais dans des conditions
particulières un rôle utile mais on voit
bien que si on voulait l'étendre il y
aurait un certain nombre de dangers en
dehors des dysfonctionnements déjà noté
par le rapporteur il y aurait les
dangers de substitution par des produits
importés et donc ceci par rapport aux
produits français donc je pense que ce
n'est pas du tout le but recherché par
monsieur le sénateur donc je l'invite à
retirer peut-être cet amendement merci
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
sénateur hoche la tête les gars tivement
donc je le mets aux voix
je me revois cet amendement qui a reçu
deux avis défavorables de la commission
et du gouvernement l'amendement numéro
34 qui et pour
qui et contre cet amendement n'est pas
adoptée je mets aux voix l'article 7 qui
et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient cet article 7 est adopté
voilà pour l'examen en seconde lecture
du projet de loi sur l'avenir de
l'agriculture un texte qui prend le
virage de l'agro écologie alors vous
pourrez revoir cette séance à tout
instant sur notre site
publicsenat.fr très bonne journée à vous
sur notre chaîne
cancun sur la côte est du mexique est
devenu le temple du sprint